così scapperemo dalla nave fantasma
nuovo gameplay horror pauroso pronti 20
temi come si fa rimontare la stessa come
mi piace esistiamo stranito non c'è il
capitano della nave qui capitano più
piccolo che cosa ci ha accordato un
ministro al contrario è in effetti agli
occhi è la bocca
vabbè marca quindi è un demone uno
zombie qualcosa si è impossessato del
capitano perché dobbiamo fare a meno e
maggiore ciao c'è scritto dietro di te
aiuto noi chi che senso non ho capito
non lo so 99 c'è un marinaio grandezza
dal capitano e là sopra e lo stesso allo
stesso capitano però la festa anche la
sovra quanti capitali ci sono questa
barca queste ma
anche qua che finisce a provà salvare
poi queste liane che cosa sono sembrano
delle donne più cazzo
se neanche inoltro liri capito o no la
bacchi parte di tutti no non è però non
so dove siamo chi riuscirà a scappare
prima io vitale
quindi prenotati
basta siamo pari
natale io
ci credo di sì spenderla da di nuovo
evitare vantaggio arendt romolo
eccolo ma noi non c'entra con la nave
forse solo potuto anch'io
pagate la data è stata presa da un
mostro il tipo dei vermi e questo sembra
un tipo delle liane tipo
crack i
biglietti vanno riparliamo il polpo
gigante faceva paura
basta
ok concentrazione non facciamoci
distrarre sia meno
nuova faccia rifatta
torna indietro ora dice di
pietro che cosa sono queste cose è
bravissima cervello
sono qui su una macchina o guarda
bruciano tutto nas a premere per fortuna
è lento
si è preso la mia preso che forse
bisogna premere un bottone che ho visto
la somma è il fattore allora chiamarci
salute che conosce
[Musica]
niente guarda essere solo macchina blu
no ma lui faremo attori sono
bebè bisogna scappare delle scappare
dice che questo questo pulsante abbia
aperto una porta sola via bisogna capire
quando si preme il pulsante
credo di sì è difficilissimo lui è
velocissimo e adesso sarebbe sbagliato
trono
un aiuto vero ecco qua riuscito a votare
sì l'ho premuto è ora dove posso
scappare un sorriso bene la porta non lo
sto trovando problemi serve un aiuto a
tenere la strada per lui niente
forse dobbiamo tornare indietro
aiuto mi sta inseguendo non mi molla più
chiuso premuto il bottone di battermi
da questa parte da questa parte cordata
guidata da un vero
stiamo tornando indietro a prestito
quando
in seguito più ho preso proprio lì e
adesso come facciamo un suo proprio
credo che dobbiamo premere nuovamente
importate che li stiamo sfracellati
troviamo
ok il pulsante è diventato verde adesso
i maschi aperto convocato le donne a due
ragazzi sono di tre sky tv sospese
lasciamo a salire la statura però guarda
qui proprio
io prima non servono anche se abbiamo
premuto giusta io non ero diventato test
sul sun per ora rossi forse era un po
bagatto e gioco
riaccenderle di nuovo quando cadi no
devi riprendere il pulsante versi
guardate passato aiutarlo tutor nella
festa cercando di prendermi ma
ovviamente non risolvere sparire manovra
schiacciate pure la pace auguro capitano
non riuscirai a prendervi
un fatto che passerà adesso c'è un
problema dovremmo stare in italia del
manico la hd nato movimento un bel
problema questo che
sappiamo siamo fino adesso ce l'ha fatta
evitare possa farcela se
c'è qualcuno che sta tornando
cioè che poi non si muove cos'è questo
un polpo che carino nuovo aspetto
è carinissimo perché tenta quali si
muove come l'ho detto
come
superare il porto è certo sono già
avantissimo dai sbrigati sbrigativo
bike pride allora qui c'è qualcuno
imprigionato il castello capitano ma che
prima casa capitale
ci sono dei dubbi qui sotto sotto le
scarpe nel verso che ha fatto sta
muovendo
non sembra che stia dormendo sembra
quasi madre
[Risate]
sono qua sotto sbrigati guarda queste in
queste skip rom 6 trovi bravo sì sempre
davanti il mio testamento
conclusi e paperelle ma cosa si parla
delle paperelle giganti e non andava
no è no allora io mi riferivo lanciando
il rifiuto di entrare nel corpo perché
so benissimo
lo so benissimo di cui dovrebbe uscire
da quella parte camera ottica di torino
venite ad evitare la cella di più come
il porto non ha motivo evidente però che
di pesciolini da esplicativo angelo
cadere
alla fine di questi gravissimi commenti
che voto gli date da 1 a 10
ok sono riuscito a superare i pesci
aspettavi sono ancora qui che non me la
disprezza il lamento che questo 144
cerchiamo 5a senato e stavolta vitale
vediamo
le auto è ancora che bollano come che
ancora questa può prendere tempo oro
azioni e un po ammaccata
non stiamo nella gola del polpo è vitale
bisogna saltare
bisogna saltare su quelle verdi bisogna
evitarle leali ma sarà marroni e un po
di verde bene barry allora questo colpo
aiutata tantissimo e mi ha superato di
nuovo come possibile italia mentre uno
fa brano vi liberate i nostri primissimi
gameplay se non li avete visti andate a
vedere perché le cose erano molto
diverse e vi farò un sacco ridere vedere
vita le mascherate distruggerla mi
sfracellasi bisogna stare attenti a
questi denti
ma perché ci sono altri tentatore ma
appunto è un po strano ma
una sorta di limbo
piccolo passo aggiusterà suscita le
possiamo prendere per certo prima di
vita
è così e spronato e le maire che bella e
vitale messo mi sto divertendo qui su
questi pochi colpi
che sta succedendo ho come l'impressione
che evitare per esser l'era varie volte
qua bisogna saltare su queste stella
marina vediamo quante volte facendo
finora non si è sfracellato
c'è mancato pochissimo
[Musica]
siamo una parte preferita di
roma
anche la morte in questo caso tutto
[Musica]
è stato molto rapido questo tipo sono
riusciti a postare su della tua ultimo
fuori cannonate quasi certa ma la parte
davanti della nave nella prua
wow forse siamo riusciti ma ti
aspettiamo a carbonara fatto uscire cioè
eravamo in un polipo gigante però adesso
siamo e che siamo di nuovo tribunale
ok aiuta strana perché i profumati può
fare si può passare bisogna saltare
sulle sulle famiglie e poi sulla
paperella possiamo guidare non quella
che andiamo contro un iceberg potrebbero
essere molto vero questo
contratto fatto tributi e tasse qualcosa
da marinaio 900 vita e andrea belfi su
una lettera che
dobbiamo andare qua e forse ma se
sappiamo su un gommone e lo monaco a
scappare dal gommone si mastica
aspetta battuto le sei
come faccio io sono il piano di sopra
non riesca va data barbari scusate
scusate nel mi ero confuso ci siamo
quasi forse siamo quasi i tagli vediamo
se non sia un capitano che ci aspetta
alla fine
aspettiamo un vitale
guarda ci sono delle vere poi di
segnalazione anziché fare cosa al
momento sono annegato
ripartono a casa sarà di nuovo
vediamo se cade di nuovo ma no perché
dovrei metterò da un tremore via scafa e
ora guido io quello io posso votare cosa
metto come si è detto molto e mi spiace
è che come abbiamo fatto ad arrivare qui
dovrebbe
comprare dice qui che cosa che non sei
il vecchio
ma se devo scegliere uno di questi pd
button ok io credo quello blu
popolare forse dobbiamo cercare il ben
15 si deve una super velocità 1 finirà
in un limbo in cui non si può uscire da
qua sono figlia di
cosima che cosa sta succedendo aiuto che
fini è che teneri sito facendo una torre
rossa che ne di stallo lamela che thai
volando e basta
ma siccome questo gioverà uno breve
troviamo il prossimo
siamo in 1 b parkour
gigante ma io sto ancora volando in
cielo
citava e laggiù fermato tutto che poi
andare avanti se vuoi ma sta andando
avanti aspetta un lato c'è qualcosa che
non va in questo parco perché quello
stava camminando la noria perché mai
chiesto
laddove in cui continuare
forse non è caricato ma incorporamento
aiuto ma che fa molto ecco sono queste
tip roma sembra un po buggata si è col
prossimo gioco abbiamo deciso di
lasciare per gioco di prima sceglierne
uno più pauroso e da un in una casa ciò
che
credo che ci siano dei personaggi sono
eliminarci e noi dobbiamo scappare
non cambia il personaggio tipo
l'ascensore in questo caso il
personaggio è quel mezzo
chi sopravvive più a lungo vince o credo
che ce la posso farcela e se questo
video da 265 mila mi piace faremo una
seconda parte in cui giochiamo se si
gioca di chi sopravvive più a lungo
vinse io sono in cui ci dà comunque solo
di far abbiamo anche una pila per
illuminare
secolo ha preso quel culo aiuto c'è
scritto che se ne andrà tra 52 secondi
quindi dobbiamo sapere di rimanere in
vita chi c'è laggiù che ci sono riusciti
a scappare a loro
mi sono spaventato scappa scappa cose ma
prima di uscire e c'è un aborto
favorito ma qui siamo al sicuro dice non
so se qua fuori tra dieci secondi arriva
il prossimo torneo cattivo guarda c'è il
pulsante core ecco perché
io sono rimasta bloccata
che succede dove
ti preso nome mi ha preso però è come se
mi avete preso lo so ma non si non si
vede arrivare il
fisico ma nyman grande a 30 secondi
dobbiamo sopravvivere 30 secondi che
anche manca molto poco
perché pur fuori può venire anche po
fuori da me è eliminato uno po fuori per
un attacco a me
5 secondi
chi sarà il prossimo a 3 a 1 per vederlo
chi è troppo per uno stand defilando un
sacco sembra che voglio eliminare i re
cattiva
ma
cos'è questo rumore
credo che sia la prima volta
gli effetti un classico senza cena
sentry
luminosa e quindi si allontana ma
dobbiamo dare
ma ci ha bloccato se bloccato nei
corridoi
ha preso qualcuno che fuori non lo so ho
sentito un rumore ma siamo ancora tutti
vivi
e non ci ha preso il fantasma e ora
vediamo chi è il prossimo
[Musica]
papa velocissime la più veloce di tutte
col river tibia cosa stesse dietro di te
no ancora
pronto
devo assolutamente uscire fuori porta
per uscire
[Applauso]
non va bene ma se l'inter è arrivata e
già mi sta ricorrendo e voleva più
affettiva è la più difficile di tutti ce
l'ha come proprio
dove la porta per uscire
ma soprattutto perché non li non si
tocca dovrebbe farmi niente sono
nascosta di un magazzino ragazzi ma
[Risate]
forse facendo non mi dire no non mi
sento certo quella porta che quel
incastrata
20 stagioni per dopo avermi sfracellato
tre volte rimane pure là dentro
jennifer qua attraverso il muro ma sto
provando ad entrare pass però non ci
riesce
per poco e questa volta forse diventa
sempre più difficile
può essere
vediamo dopo tanto tempo tremi
problemi anche fino al fatto di greg fin
ora non sappiamo come padrini non avere
un fidanzato anche un marito il nonno
grappa greta
dov'è mia sfracellato
si è rifatta il look un po differente no
io voglio vedere non mi interessa se il
rischio di essere fratelli ciao
ecco dove credi come allora corri
gremita stare qui e qui mi trattano
londra grendi passato li leggo
si faccia a faccia hanno visto l'uomo
però tutti qua fuori
c'è il bastone vetro facciamo non
prendermi ma non ci riesce perché c'è il
vetro noto
che
ha preso attraverso scendere sono come è
possibile
che
non ci prenderebbero di loro sa
sfracellato tra mafia berlusconi
vediamo se qualcuno che conosciamo
alex
[Musica]
questo periodo
credo proprio di sì per tenere eliminato
un paio di giocatori qui questo sarebbe
opportuno ma io posso schiacciato
no credo di no
ok ragazzi proviamo a sopravvivere
all'ultimo casato un po chi è
chi è il prossimo cattivo loro
che cos'è un euro e the moon leggo che
chiedono che sembrava un mix tra un
debole uno dei sintomi non mi dire che
di cosa fa la gente perché mi sono
sempre buoni corridori
vista piaciuto a fettine
credo che lei sia chi scherza cena mia
sfracellato
accesso come li ma che cos'è come si fa
ma è questo il cattivo chi ha un
coltello gigante è tracciato di 1 bis a
più di uso e mi stavo sfoggia andando
tutti ok qua fuori sia mare sicuro credo
che anche questo incazzino è un
personaggio ma sai che non riesco a
capire marca sono scrive il trucco è
tutto strano questo gioco
che comunque tornerà fortuna che brume
approvato proprio messaggio
e come se volete che continuiamo prova a
sopravvivere e ora vi lasciamo 4 caceres
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
le carte su quella buona visione